What we will be talking about is just
different techniques and ways to
optimize the 60 frames per second
section of the web optimization project.
So what is this 60 frames per second?
Just want to remind everyone
who are on project four, or
who will be on going on project four,
is that you need to achieve 65 per
second when you are scrolling.
So basically when you're browsing, when
you're scrolling through the website
on the pizzas page, all those little
pizzas that are animating and
the background should be
rendered at 60 frames per second.
So let's first look at
the Google Dev tools and
see what does that really mean.
This is Google Dev Tools here.
This is what recording
the timeline look like.
And if you can see here,
what I basically did I launched
the Dev Tools and
I picked on the Timeline option.
I then look in and record my timeline
I press this black button here and
then I scroll up and down here.
And Google Dev Tools will give
me a nice timeline of that.
It will tell, okay,
how much time it takes to calculate
my events using my scripting.
How much time it takes to
lay out my elements, or
how much time does it take
to paint my elements.
As you can see here,
these individual bars,
they all should be lower than
the story parts per second line.
We do not even see the 60
frames per second.
Because the calculations were so high
that it's beyond 60 frames per second.
It's actually lower than
30 frames per second.
So basically what we want to do is be,
we want to squish and
lower the height of these bars.
So low that the 60 frames per
second line will show up and
we could then be able to see okay, what
are we achieve 60 frames per second.
So we're going to walk through
different stages of an optimization,
and we're going to show
you how it will look like
once you optimize certain
things of your code.
So the first thing that I want to
show you realize here is the code.
Whenever we scroll, we're going to
launch this function here at line 577.
So window.addEventListener scroll.
So it's going to listen to
the event whenever a user scrolls,
it's going to launch this function here,
optimization.
And this is the actual function
that we need to optimize.
There we go.
And then, we're going to scroll up and
try to look at
the definition of positions.
So it's right here.
So basically we know that we need
to somehow optimize this function.
Because guess what, from our timeline as
you can see, if I were to click on one
bar or one frame, it takes a lot of
time to actually calculate all of
our calculations to be able to calculate
all the pizzas that's scrolling.
So basically this is how you
should read this scroll event,
is that you had this event scroll.
This takes up a lot of time.
And then the next event will be,
recalculate style, it goes into layout,
it goes into paint.
It's painting the actual
pixels on screen.
And then it does some other previous
calculations that are not so
trivial but basically,
the main bottleneck looks like this
yellow thing which is onEventScroll.
If you click and expand this,
you see this function call here.
And this function call
is update positions.
So that's optimization.
So I already know that
I have a bottleneck.
We go in, step through this function, I
commented this function fairly well and
I just comment it with my questions and
my observations.
So basically your first step
is to look at each line and
really understand what
each line is trying to do.
In this case,
I am getting all the pizzas from here
because all the pizzas that
are animating has a class name mover.
I'm going through a for loop and
then I'm changing some,
I'm doing a lot of
calculations here on line 31.
And then,
I then do this calculation here on
line 541 to actually change
the left position on each pizza.
Now the first thing
that I want to ask is,
is okay, focusing on really,
on this part right here.
Is that okay, in order for
me to understand whether this loop is
efficient or not,
let's log out all these numbers and see.
Let's log out.
Basically what I would do,
I would like basically do a console log.
I'll log off the base number and it will
log out the document.body.scroll and and
basically, any other type of variable
that is the being calculated.
And I want to see which
variables are really crucial for
me to be inside my for
loop which can be outside the for loop.
Because basically I'm thinking
inside a for loop and
this is the majority
of instructions here.
I'm doing a lot of calculations
per loop, and I'm trying to think.
Is there any way for
me to reduce the amount of time to
calculate these complex calculation?
And notice that another optimization
that I'm looking at is,
when the DOM has been loaded.
This basically says if
the page has been loaded,
I'm going to create 200 pizzas
that will be animating.
And assigned them the class mover,
right.
So, because basically all the animated
pizzas are assigned the class mover.
That's when we know those
are the pizzas that should be animated.
And I want to ask myself, here's 200
pizzas that should be animated but
then if I go back to my pizzas page,
I'm only seeing a handful
of the pizzas that are animating
at any point in time.
So my second question, do I
necessary need to animate 200 pizzas
if only a handful of them
are showing up on my screen?
So food for thought for everyone.
I'm giving everyone hints, I'm actually
not going to give anyone the answers but
hopefully this will give you guys and
gals good enough hints for
you to start thinking about
certain aspects to your
function and to try to basically
pick apart every line of the code.
And try to ask yourself,
can I make each line efficient
as much as possible.
Basically if I were to make those
optimizations that I talked about,
I'm going to get a timeline like this.
As you can see,
this timeline is drastically different.
So now we can see the 60 FPS timeline,
and this is the goal.
Our goal is to be able to
basically get all the color bars
underneath this 60
frames per second line.
And if I were to actually go and
click on a bar here,
select a bar, basically.
Reduce my timeline.
I can see on my bed scroll,
my yellow here.
Which used to take up the whole time.
The whole 16.667 milliseconds.
It has been drastically
reduced to around
point 6.2 milliseconds for scripting.
If you look at the numbers to
my lower right hand corner.
It went from 25 milliseconds
to 0.642 milliseconds, so
that's pretty good optimization.
And actually for,
just to meet the minimal qualifications,
this is good enough.
We still have a couple of other things
that we could increase optimizations on,
especially the paint here,
because the green bar's here.
And a little bit of the purple bar here
because this is actually the layout.
Remember our stages in rendering
from the web optimization file.
We have the HTML, the DOM,
we then download the seesaw we look at
the JavaScript and
we go into the render tree.
Then after that we'd go into layout.
That should lay out the elements,
and then we actually paint.
So this actually shows you
the relationship of okay,
I have event JavaScript.
I'm going to do layout.
Since I've rendered my
rendered shit already.
I go and paint and
then I basically rinse and repeat.
If you think about it,
this yellow line could actually
be reduced a little bit more.
We can actually have a little bit
more opposition from our JavaScript.
And we can actually get rid
of one of these stages called
mainly the layout stage.
So let's go back into the code and
figure out what else can we do.
So the first thing that we see that any
other things that we can squeeze out,
any other performances
using query selector, all.
Because basically there's a more
efficient way to access your DOM,
and that's using
document.getElementsByClass.
This is actually a more efficient way to
get all the piece of elements and mover.
So this is actually good way
to make things more efficient.
Another one is this line here.
This modular operator here.
If you notice.
Let's let's go back to understand
what the modular operator is.
The modular operator,
I'm looking at my notes,
gives us the remainder
when we divide 1 by 5.
So it's a remainder.
It's not a division it's a remainder.
So basically if i is 1,
1 remainder of 5 is one.
2 remainder of 5 is 2.
3 remainder of 5 is 3, and so forth.
And these numbers repeat itself, so
basically we will have in
a nutshell if you do all the math.
This will be just five numbers.
No matter how many pizzas you have,
whether it be 200 pizzas or
a thousand pizzas.
Every time you iterate you will only
have five unique numbers because
the module operator basically
gives us just the remainder.
And we fix the base number of five.
So If you think about it,
why can't we just store five numbers and
then use those numbers to change
the position of our element?
One last thing here is
a lot of people have wrote
on the forum is to use some sort of
CSS3 hardware acceleration here.
Because basically CSS3 has
hardware acceleration and
certain transformations that reduce
the need to retrigger a read layout.
Basically what I'm talking about is
a lot of people used to translateX.
And if you look it up, there's some
articles that talk about this,
here's the hack to increase your speed.
So again, you could do this
instead of using style.left,
you use transfprm translateX to
actually position your element.
Now, what this does is this gets rid
of the need to trigger a read layout.
And if you think about it,
it just basically gets rid of
one event in the purple bar.
And a lot of people says you need
to do this, you must do that.
If you think about, let's go back and
look at the numbers.
Once we do that, this doesn't really
make that much of a difference.
It does but in this case,
you can get away with perfectly
using this level of code.
For every scroll I'm
repainting the whole screen.
Now the question is, is there a way for
me to only paint the moving pizzas and
not the rest of the screen.
Because everything else doesn't need
to get repainted because the pixels
are still good.
So is there a way for
me to reduce this green bar too.
So I can reduce these total
bars to basically near zero.
How we're going to do that,
this is a hacky way, so
I want to preface that, that there
are tradeoffs to doing the tech way.
So just be aware as
a developer of the tradeoffs.
So there's a hacky way
to reduce the paint now.
because basically what we do,
is that we tell the browser to
actually render our pizzas,
our individual pizzas,
and put them into individual
composite layers.
because basically, even if there
is one pixel that's changed,
the whole layer gets repainted.
So what we do is,
we put all of our individual pizzas
into their individual layers.
Now how can we do that?
We actually do some CSS hacks.
The hack that I'm going to use is
called backface-visibility: hidden.
I'm actually going to use
this hack to actually force
the browser to render each
pizza element in its own layer.
So basically,
if I were to animate it now, and
these pizzas are in their own layer,
it means that I only need to paint
a small section of the screen,
and not the whole screen.
So how you would do that is,
you basically
put this backface-visibility: hidden
in the [INAUDIBLE] class in your CSS.
So let's go back to the timeline.
So basically this is what
our current performance is.
If I choose backface-visibility: hidden,
this is the timeline.
And we can see here all of the green
basically no painting involved at all.
So I have a lot of extra bandwidth and
memory now be able to
do additional things.
I would say this is a very smooth frame
rate because you're barely hitting
no more than a half of
your available bandwidth
to be able to render each frame.
There's one caveat.
So here's the caveat,
here's the tradeoff.
So painting here, if you look at this,
painting here is reduced from two
milliseconds to about
a half a millisecond.
But the time to fix the script and
to render it should increase but
just from 0.5 scripting here
to 2 milliseconds scripting.
And then we went basically four or
five milliseconds rendering to
almost three milliseconds rendering.
And that's the trail that you have to
take because this is my hypothesis,
I haven't confirmed this,
the more layers you put on,
that there's probably more overhead that
you need to do, and you need to track.
But if you look at the overall
net performance that's
probably a good tradeoff.
For mobile devices here,
this hack can really do a number on
mobile devices with low video memory.
Because basically,
this hack is forcing the GPU or
the video card to actually render those
pizzas for us instead of the CPU.
If a mobile device has
low video memory or
it's not a very fast device,
performance may actually be poorer.
The best way to really find out
what trials to use is to use these
development tools that were given us.
And also to test the performance
on other devices.